our main story tonight concerns
electricity it's like oscar isaac in
that without its involvement nothing in
my house gets turned on
electricity is such an integral part of
modern life it is hard to believe that
we used to have to sell people on the
idea of electric appliances with ads
like this when you step inside the total
electric home you step into an entirely
new concept in living
organized around electric centers
such as this entertainment center the
pride and joy of the man of the house is
the weather control center a center that
puts you in charge of the electric
heating and air conditioning and the
electronic air filtering of the entire
house yes the pride and joy of the man
of the house is of course the
temperature control system just invite
all your thermo bros over on a sunday
crack open a few brews and watch the
temperature for hours sorry ladies you
wouldn't understand it's a guy thing
specifically tonight we're going to talk
about the power grid the system of
generators that produce electricity and
the vast lattice work of wires that get
it to our homes the grid is something
that you probably don't think much about
until it goes down which unfortunately
has been happening more and more in
recent years
millions of texans woke up to cold homes
when the power grid failed this video
shows lights going out as parts of the
power grid failed that power grid failed
yesterday when hurricane ida ravaged
parts of louisiana the lights went out
across downtown detroit cutting power to
1400 buildings watch as the lights go
out during a murder trial these lawyers
left in the dark holy
when the lights go out during a murder
trial one of two things is happening
you've either got a power grid deeply in
need of repair or the murder victim has
come back as a ghost and is seeking
revenge either way your priorities have
shifted and it's time to focus on a much
bigger problem
if it feels like there have been more
outages than usual recently that's
because there have by one estimate from
2015 to 2020 the number of annual
blackouts in the us doubled and that is
not good for numerous reasons the most
obvious being sitting around without
power for any period of time absolutely
sucks what are you supposed to do
without tv and the internet go outside
that's where snakes live yeah idiots
so what else you're supposed to do read
a book that's where snakes sleep you're
idiots
why do you think we invented kindles
but it is not just inconvenience losing
electricity wreaks havoc on everything
from sewage treatment plants to water
purification systems and can be
life-threatening to people who rely on
medical equipment like ventilators and
powered wheelchairs it's traumatizing
it's terrifying for tur horst an outage
is more than just an expensive
inconvenience this isn't like i'm going
to lose
a casserole in my fridge
you know this is i may not be alive
tomorrow
exactly this is clearly about much more
than just lost casseroles especially
because and let's be honest here all
casseroles are they don't rely on
specific ingredients so much as
whatever's in someone's house casseroles
are a sad smokers board of other
leftovers desperately cobbled together
to make a pathetic almost meal with
names like tuna surprise and chicken i'm
sorry but to have a casserole left over
that is abandoned food that didn't make
the cut two rounds in a row i'm sorry
but if that is your only option there
are genuinely worse fates than being
dead and look while things are bad now
they could get a lot worse in the future
because the u.s has a goal of net zero
carbon emissions by 2050 which we
absolutely must meet but one study
estimates that's going to require a 40
to 60 percent increase in peak
electricity consumption which when you
think about it does make sense if we are
switching to electric cars cooking and
heating all that electricity is going to
have to come from somewhere and the
truth is if everyone suddenly had an
electric car tomorrow that might be
great for the planet but it could push
our grid to its absolute limit so
tonight let's talk about the power grid
the current state that it's in and what
we can do to fix it let's start with the
fact that while i'm saying grid singular
our system is actually made up of three
grids there is the eastern
interconnection the western
interconnection and the texas
interconnection it's basically like
major league baseball in that there are
two dominant groups and then arseholes
in texas who'd rather make up their own
rules
and it all started in 1882 right here in
new york when thomas edison unveiled the
country's first central power station on
pearl street interestingly it was then
edison's sometime rival nikola tesla who
helped develop the technology enabling
electricity to travel for long distances
something all the more remarkable given
tesla's
let's say
eccentricities
tesla suffered from bizarre compulsions
like his consuming need to rescue
injured pigeons and nurse them back to
health
he has an infirmary for them right
outside his bedroom window where he's
trying to heal you know some that have
broken wings broken legs and in fact at
one point he actually referred to one
bird has his wife
and he said you know when she died
the inventive spirit left him
did it now
look this isn't the point of this story
or really anything but if tesla were
alive today i genuinely wonder which
would upset him more the fact that his
name has been co-opted by history's
first edgelord billionaire or the fact
that modern pigeons have just gotten so
unfuckable listen i said no respectfully
thank you for your attention but i'm not
interested please leave me and my
friends alone
and when it was built our power grid
wasn't just a technical marvel it was a
civic one until the 1930s electricity
was a luxury mainly for dense urban
areas of the country but after fdr
created the rural electrification
administration in 1935 that began to
change
the rea was set up by the president and
the congress in 1935
to help farmers to get the power and
light at a price they can afford here is
the first thing women ask for after
light itself
if you have ever ironed for an hour
you'll know why
an electric iron may not look important
to a man but it lightens one whole day's
burden for a woman yes don't worry
ladies with hubby naturally busy staring
at the thermostat
you'll have plenty to do to occupy your
time like ironing his clothes or
teaching a different woman to iron his
clothes and if there is still time
pressing the iron to your neck just for
a moment simply to feel something you
thought getting lights would make things
better but it only made things clearer
didn't it
now in the end we wound up with 600 000
miles of transmission lines and around
five and a half million miles of local
distribution lines like the ones that
you might see outside of your house all
of which form our modern electrical grid
it has been called the supreme
engineering achievement of the 20th
century which is not to say that it is
completely invulnerable of course not
when you string wires in the air they're
going to be subject to interference from
all sorts of things a website that
tracked disruptions found that they've
been over 600 outages caused by
squirrels over 200 by birds 53 by
raccoons and a number of others caused
by everything from snakes to slugs let
me just quickly say here
kudos slugs
out of everything on that list you are
honestly the ones that i underestimated
the nicest thing i can say about you is
that on your best day you look like
sassy poop but
you really showed us something by
disrupting our power so once more slugs
kudos
but is not just animals that can wreak
havoc they've also been multiple
balloon-based disruptions and if you're
wondering how on earth a balloon could
cause a power outage the answer is like
this
[Music]
excellent
not one single note i hope no one
standing there was hurt but honestly
even if someone was it wouldn't be a
deal breaker for me
but disruptions have always been an
issue for the power grid what makes it
especially vulnerable now is a
combination of two key factors the first
is old age most power lines were
constructed in the 50s and 60s with a
50-year life expectancy which they are
clearly now well past and the second is
climate change meaning there's now more
danger posed by extreme weather like
hurricanes tornadoes and abnormally hot
or cold temperatures and that combo of
old equipment and new climate threats
has been disastrous the massive campfire
in california a few years ago happened
because there was a drought in the area
making it essentially a tinderbox and in
intense winds some pacific gas and
electric equipment failed and for a
pretty infuriating reason this is the
hook that killed
84 people
that groove took
about 98 years
to wear in it's not a defect
these hooks are what are holding the
electrical lines off the ground
and pg e's decision was simply just to
let these things hang until they broke
when this old hook did break the power
line made contact with the metal tower
showering the ground in sparks
that's how pg e started the campfire
yeah and let that be a lesson to you you
can't just keep something that old in
place and expect it to keep working
forever pg e basically took the same
approach to their equipment as democrats
did with ruth bader ginsburg and in both
cases it didn't end well
so basically we've got a power grid
built in the 20th century that is not
equipped to deal with the needs and
stresses of the 21st and if you think
well okay
let's upgrade it then yeah absolutely
right but that is also a massive
undertaking because there are a lot of
fixes both small and huge that the power
grid badly needs the small ones we don't
have time to get into tonight like
investing in microgrids and
weatherproofing as well as better
storage capabilities so the excess power
we generate doesn't go to waste but
we're going to focus on the huge one
here because our shift to renewable
energy is going to require a fundamental
shift in what our grid looks like one of
the few benefits of fossil fuel plants
is that you can put them anywhere that
is why most are located near densely
populated areas close to the people that
they serve but you can't just replace
every coal plant with a wind farm
because that is not necessarily where
the wind is strongest and that fact
alone changes everything
this is a model created by princeton
mapping out possible places in the
continental u.s where wind and solar
projects could in theory be built
aside from some offshore wind farms it's
mostly in the middle of the u.s
another study found that these states
have most of the wind and solar
potential yet the people living there
would only make up 30 of the electricity
demand
in a decarbonized future we're going to
need to get electricity from here to
here
right and you probably don't even need
me to tell you why this is going to be
an uphill battle because as soon as you
saw that graphic and realized updating
the grid was going to require a
princeton researcher telling a
midwestern farmer we need to build
something in your backyard so someone in
california can power their electric car
you already called the next eight
election cycles for republicans
but there is actually some good news
here because we've already made
considerable progress in building out
renewable energy power sources last year
for the first time ever renewables like
solar wind and hydropower accounted for
the largest portion of new generating
capacity and that is good not just for
consumers but in many cases for the
communities where those facilities are
built in 2019 wind energy projects alone
provided 706 million dollars in land
lease payments to rural land owners so
entire towns and areas can benefit from
the money and the jobs renewables can
bring as this mayor in wyoming can
attest my personal belief is it provides
money it provides jobs taxes and then i
look at the towns that they're by and
just think of what people have that they
wouldn't have had
a lot of infrastructure police cars
those kind of things when i look at a
wind farm all i think about is cha-ching
and that's great well to be clear when
you look at a wind farm you can't think
to ching because that's the cash
register noise i know you're trying to
make a different point but this is
important too wind farms go through
that's how wind farms go a cash register
goes to ching a solar farm goes
a cat on the day everyone forgot his
birthday goes meow
a horny cartoon wolf goes ugh and again
wind farms go
just so we're clear about how things go
so the physical generation of renewable
energy isn't really the problem here the
key issue is the transmission of it
basically how do you get that energy
from where it's made like a wind farm in
wyoming to where it is needed which
could be a thousand miles away and that
brings us to transmission lines because
they are at the absolute heart of our
grid and we're going to need a lot more
of them partly because due to
limitations of our aging transmission
infrastructure in some places we
actually have more electricity than we
have the capability to transport for
instance in vermont they had to put a
moratorium on new solar and wind
projects because the transmission lines
couldn't carry any more electricity so
building out newer
higher capacity lines is crucially
important but so far
we haven't done nearly enough and that
is for a couple of reasons the first big
one is location stringing power lines
out across the country is a logistical
nightmare unlike interstate gas lines
which only require approval from the
federal energy regulatory commission
with power lines you must secure the
buy-in from multiple state and local
agencies in every state you pass through
alongside all the individual landowners
whose property you need to use and look
there are legitimate reasons for people
to not want power lines in their
backyard for instance if it disrupts
their farming operation or goes through
environmentally sensitive areas or
cultural or sacred sites for native
americans other objections are simply
aesthetic the fact is high voltage lines
capable of carrying more electricity
require bigger towers than their
predecessors and some people just don't
want to see them this is such an issue
that some countries have actually made
efforts to beautify their towers in
hungary they decided to build ones that
look like jesters
in iceland they proposed these designs
for a project called land of giants and
in argentina there is colossal the giant
transmission line robots at night
colossal lights up and can even smile
and wink and look i get the smile part
you want colossal to come off as
friendly so children aren't terrified of
the giant electrified robot with glowing
monster eyes but why does it need to
wink
what is it trying to communicate there
is it coming on to us because i feel the
same way about colossal as i do about
that pigeon never in a million
years no thank you please stop looking
at me like that it's making me
uncomfortable it's my friend's birthday
we're just trying to give her a nice
evening although i will i will keep the
long island iced tea thank you
and good night
and the thing is
local opposition can be very effective
in killing transmission line projects a
few years back a company proposed plans
to build 16 miles of new lines through
pennsylvania but local landowners formed
a grassroots group to push back even
releasing videos like this one to detail
their objections i understand everybody
needs electric and everybody has to have
electric i wouldn't want to be without
electric but from what i understand
you know
this is only going to help people in
western pa
maryland and virginia
and what's it do you know i mean i i
chose to live here
and they chose to live there so don't
make your problem my problem
that's that's how i feel
okay i mean that is a little bit
maddening the mirrored sunglasses
definitely don't help but it's a lot
more than that because i do get i don't
want this on my land i really do but to
make your argument i don't want this
here if it'll only help someone there
just makes you sound like a dick also if
we don't upgrade the grid absolutely
everyone is going to have problems
including you it's like saying don't
make your problem my problem when your
neighbor's yard is full of bears sure
but when it gets over that fence guess
what it's your problem now too
and when you consider all the hurdles
transmission projects have to clear it
is no wonder it can take up to a decade
to get new ones approved if they're
approved at all and this can make it
harder to bring renewable energy onto
the grid in the first place fewer than a
quarter of proposed energy projects like
solar and wind actually ever make it to
commercial operation because of
transmission hurdles and that is really
not good now the second big obstacle to
overcome here is cost because the truth
is this won't be cheap one study
projects decarbonizing our power grid
could cost two and a half trillion
dollars over the next decade and to put
it mildly not everyone is on board with
spending that money when congress was
considering the clean future act a bill
that would among other things provide
for expanding our transmission system
representative bill johnson absolutely
refused to entertain the notion that it
could possibly be worth it and would not
back down whether the american people
are stuck picking up this tab the higher
taxes or rate increases on their utility
bills
can you honestly say that they'll be
receiving a return on their investment
as you look at the cost benefit for
the
health and safety of communities what's
the return on the investment what is the
return on investment they're making a
monetary
investment with their taxes or their
rate increases
what is the return on their investment
so the return on the investment is
access to clean energy it's access to no
that's not a return on investment a
return on investment is a monetary thing
that's why you make an investment okay a
few things one
shut up
two
if you let her talk for more than two
seconds there she might have
told you that many studies have found
that it is cost effective for instance a
federal lab looked into expanding
transmission lines across the country
and found that such a project could
return up to two dollars and fifty cents
in benefits for every dollar of cost
which is as an might put it a
return a return on a investment
set that aside set aside also that
blackouts can cost us a lot of money as
the people of texas will tell you after
what happened to them earlier this year
there are also many benefits here that
are not purely monetary a cleaner grid
helps combat climate change meaning that
maybe your grandkids won't die in weekly
lava hurricanes which does seem pretty
worthwhile framing this purely as a
matter of debt profit is so weird it's
like saying what's the return on
investment in funding the fire
department how much money do we make of
that well i guess technically none but
if your house is on fire someone will
come with a hose to put it out plus we
get those sexy firefighter calendars
full of oiled up fire hunks so we get to
be safer and hornier i'd call it a
win-win
and look i admit this is going to
require a lot of compromise and
flexibility from all of us but there are
ways to overcome the hurdles that i've
described tonight when it comes to
transmission line location we can ease
people's concerns not necessarily by
going full creepy colossal here we don't
have to be winked at but we can make
sure that people are compensated fairly
for the use of their property and place
lines to the extent possible on already
disturbed lands like along railroads and
highways and when it comes to cost we
are finally making some progress the
infrastructure bill that passed the
house this week devotes over 65 billion
dollars to improve the power grid with a
portion going directly to transmission
upgrades and expansion it is a good
start while also being not nearly enough
but the key thing going forward here
might be to start thinking about this
differently than we currently are
because for far too long whenever we've
experienced blackouts we've tended to
think of it as the power grid failing
but the truth is it's not failing us we
are failing it by asking to do something
it was not designed to do in conditions
that it was not designed to handle so we
need to act boldly and quickly as if
both our lives and our shitty casseroles
depend on it
and if we do this if we manage to
properly upgrade our power grid it will
genuinely be one of the biggest
accomplishments of the 21st century and
one
definitely worth celebrating perhaps i
don't know with some balloons you know
balloons are always fun aren't they
their lips are oh oh oh
oh
oh no oh uh
uh hold on i'm okay
uh
that's our show
[Applause]
thanks so much for watching we'll see
you next week good
good night thank you that's it
which way is uh
i'm gonna go
i'm gonna go this way look
it's over here
we'll be back next week
we'll be back
you